ich rufe nun auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
28 a bis 28 g
Beratung mehrerer Vorlagen zur
finanziellen Stabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung zur
Krankenhausfinanzierung sowie zur
Arzneimittelsicherheit und Versorgung
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die Bundesregierung der
Bundesminister für Gesundheit Professor
Dr Karl Lauterbach
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Lieben und
Kollegen und Kollegen lassen Sie mich
auch bitte beginnen indem ich den
Angehörigen von Rainer ganz herzlich
mein Beileid Ausdrücke er war auch für
unser Haus immer ein wichtiger
Ansprechpartner ein wichtiger Ratgeber
wir werden den vermissen
die gesetzliche Regelung die wir heute
besprechen in der Krankenversicherung
ist der Tatsache geschuldet dass in der
letzten Legislaturperiode den Aufbau
eines großen Defizits in der
Krankenversicherung gegeben hat in
dieser Größe in Ordnung kann man sagen
historisch entstanden durch den
demografischen Wandel in unserer
Gesellschaft die bessere Technologie
aber auch der Tatsache dass hier
Strukturreformen ausgeblieben sind das
ist keine Kritik sondern dass der
Tatsache geschuldet dass andere
Schwerpunkte im Vordergrund gestanden
sind die pandemiebekämpfung somit ist es
ein geerbtes Defizit aber das werden wir
gemeinsam beseitigen wir müssen es
beseitigen in dem Geist keine
Schuldzuweisungen aber gemeinsam daran
gehen und dabei habe ich mich oder dabei
haben wir uns im Haus auch von drei
Grundprinzipien leiten lassen das
wichtigste Grundprinzip bin ich im
Vordergrund stellen und daran werden wir
nicht rütteln werden wenn der gesamten
Legislaturperiode nicht rütteln wir
wollen keine Land Leistungskürzungen
Leistungskürzungen in einer Zeit wo die
Menschen bedroht sind durch Krieg
Inflation steigende Energiepreise
möglicherweise Rezession das ist eine
Situation wo Kürzungen der
Gesundheitsversorgung nicht vermittelbar
sind mir wird das immer wieder
vorgeschlagen ich lehne dies ab wir
müssen in einer solchen Zeit
zusammenhalten es kann nicht sein dass
die Menschen in solchen Phase
gesundheitskostungen
Einschränkungen im Leistungskatalog
hinlegen das werden wir nicht mitmachen
das haben wir da durch diese Reform
getragen ich bitte dafür auch um die
Unterstützung im ganzen Haus ganz im
Haus diese Sicherheit müssen wir den
Menschen bieten auch in der in dem in
der Gefahr im Wandel auf die
Gesundheitsversorgung kann man sich
verlassen zum zweiten es ist richtig
dass wir zuerst ein Effizienzreserven
herangehen bevor wir Beitragssätze
werden und in diesem System sind viele
Effizienzreserven einige der wichtigen
Effizienzreserven werden wir ja nicht
wird ein paar Beispiele nachher bringen
was durch Effizienz Reserven nicht
gewinnbar ist das muss dann fair
verteilt werden die lassen die dann
übrig bleiben über Steuermittel dann
aber auch über moderate
Beitragssatzerhöhung aber auch unter
Beteiligung der Arbeitgeber sage ich
ausdrücklich denn die Zusatzbeiträge
sind ja paritätisch bezahlt es kann
nicht sein dass alles Beiträge der
Arbeitnehmer und der Steuerzahler sind
die arbeitgeberbeteiligen sich nicht
daher eine faire Verteilung auf alle
Schultern ist richtig und die stärksten
schultern müssen das Maße tragen
wieso sind hier noch Effizienzreserven
vorhanden also wie kann es überhaupt
sein ich bringe ein Beispiel die
Krankenkassen haben durch die
Wettbewerbsverzerrungen die es früher
gegeben hat auch ganz unterschiedliche
Rücklagen es gibt also Krankenkassen die
haben hohe klagen und es gibt
Krankenkassen die haben sehr niedrige
Rücklagen das verzehrt natürlich den
Wettbewerb und somit müssen diese
Rücklagen zuerst einmal der Versorgung
zugeführt werden wenn wir das nicht tun
dann passiert das was wir jetzt auch als
es angekündigt wurde zu sehen war die
Krankenkassen die viele Rücklagen haben
die stocken zum Beispiel ihre eigenen
vorstandsalters Rückstellung massiv auf
es sind tatsächlich auch Krankenkassen
ich möchte hier wirklich nicht in eine
polemische begeister einsteigen aber es
sind Krankenkassen wo die Vorstände
deutlich mehr verdienen als der
Bundeskanzler auch darüber muss
nachgedacht werden die also
Altersrückstellung sind so hoch dass
hier Vergütungen bezahlt werden können
die unvergleichbar sind was der normale
körperversicherte verdient da diese
Rückstellungen zurückzuführen halte ich
für richtig insbesondere in einer Zeit
wo wir sonst an die Beitragssätze heran
müssen oder die Versicherten belasten
müssen
ich will ein paar Beispiele kurz dafür
bringen wir so wie Effizienzreserven
gehoben haben wo die Versorgung nicht
schlecht aber ich bin ein Beispiel was
wir zum hier zum Beispiel machen wir
bereinigen im Krankenhaus das
pflegebudget war die Pflege wird jetzt
was gut ist über die Kostendeckung
direkt erstattet es gibt aber beim
Pflege Budget noch eine rechtskonstante
in der fahrpauschale somit wird dort die
Pflege doppelt abgerechnet das haben wir
beseitigt das ist einfach fair und
richtig da wird die Versorgung nicht
schlechter oder wir haben beispielsweise
im Bereich der Arzneimitteltherapie
dafür gesorgt dass also sehr hohe Preise
mit den neuen Medikamenten in den Markt
kommen das kann in dieser Form sowieso
nur noch in Deutschland passieren wir
sind daher der innovationsfreundlichste
Pharmamarkt in ganz Europa die
Pharmafirmen wollen vieles verändern
aber sie wollen kein anderes
Vergütungssystem aus Europa nur unseres
aber wir haben dann tatsächlich die Zeit
wo diese hohen Preise unverändert gelten
die haben wir auf sechs Monate ge das
ist einfach fair es kann nicht sein dass
ein Preis der belegter Weise zu hoch ist
dann noch sechs Monate in der überhöhten
Form weiter genommen wird das ist
einfach unfair das Effizienz Reserve das
ist im lobbydruck der vergangenen Jahre
geschuldet das haben wir beseitigt in
einer solchen Zeit müssen wir auch
gemahlen sein bei allem Verständnis für
die Lobbygruppen die bei uns jeden Tag
Vorsprechen müssen wir für die
Versicherten müssen wir für die
Verbraucher die Steuerzahler die
Beitragszahler stehen und das haben wir
in dieser Reform gewagt und werden uns
auch weiter tun bei unberechtigten
Angriffen werden wir dem lobbydruck
standhalten das sind wir den
Versicherten den Menschen in Deutschland
schuldig sonst schlagt der Beitragssatz
unnötigerweise das ist nicht den zu
nehmen
es war nicht alles durch also
Effizienzreserven gewinnbar ich könnte
weitere Beispiele bringen zum Schluss
ist dann doch noch etwas übrig geblieben
was wir fair verteilen müssen da
belasten wir den Steuerzahler der
Zuschuss steigt um 2 Milliarden Euro wir
arbeiten kurzfristig mit einem Darlehen
von einer Milliarde Euro um die
Schuldenbremse nicht zu also
überschreiten und wir erhöhen den
Beitragssatz um 0,3 auch das ist nicht
unfair weil im Gegensatz zu
Steuermitteln bezahlt hier der
Arbeitgeber die Hälfte mit also die
Arbeitgeber werden mit ins Boot genommen
somit diese gleich die ja auch die
gesetzliche krankenversichert auch die
Gesetze aber es ist nur 0,15
beitragssatzpunkt mehr ist es nicht der
allergrößte Teil der allergrößte Teil
über das auf den Punkt zu bringen der
allergrößte Plan 90 Prozent dieser
Reform werden nicht durch die Erhöhungen
des Beitragssatzes 90% nicht durch die
Erhöhung des Beitragssatzes auf
gkv-seite auf der Arbeitnehmerseite
bezahlen 90 Prozent diese zehn Prozent
haben wir zugemutet das halte ich aber
auch für vertretbar es sind zehn Prozent
90 Prozent werden über andere Quellen
also werden die generiert ich komme zum
Schluss wir werden hier folgendes also
feststellen nach der Reform ist vor der
Reform weil wir brauchen tatsächlich
langfristig eine wesentliche
Strukturreform der Art und Weise wie die
Krankenversicherung bezahlen ich habe
jetzt hier einmal Effizienz Reserven
mobilisiert die in keinem Fall zu einer
Verschlechterung der Versorgung für den
km/harzigen Fall aber langfristig müssen
wir natürlich die Reform bringen und
daran arbeiten wir auch wir müssen
tatsächlich die Beiträge für
Arbeitslosengeld II Empfänger die müssen
wir fairer gestalten erhöhen wir müssen
den Bundeszuschuss den es gibt
dynamisiert kann nicht sein dass die
Menschen immer älter werden der
Tourismus wird nicht dynamisiert und
somit wir aber noch arbeiten auch an
dieser Reform aber ich bitte einfach um
Verständnis dass wir die
Effizienzreserven erst einmal heben
müssen dann gehen wir an diese Reform
diese Brücke werden wir überschreiten
wenn wir Sie erreichen und wir werden
auch kurzfristig das möchte ich auch
noch sagen für die erheblichen
Energiekosten die Krankenhäuser haben
die inflationskosten für die
Mehrbelastungen in der Pflege bei den
Eigenanteilen auch dafür werde ich von
dieser Stelle in Zukunft in Kürze
Vorschläge Vorbringen aber wir müssen
das getrennt sehen Effizienzreserven die
Reform von heute eine Finanzreform die
Reform von morgen und dann die
Beseitigung der Belastungen Eigenanteile
in der Pflege aber auch in den also in
den Krankenhäusern das ist die Reform
ebenfalls die in Kürze vorgestellt
werden so dass wir das gemeinsam
schaffen bitte unterstützen Sie diese
Reformen versparen Sie uns mit Polemik
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam über Lösungen
nachdenken danke Ihnen für die
Aufmerksamkeit
mit mit einem Appell Ende der
Bundesgesundheitsminister nachdem er
erläutert hat seine Vorstellungen wie
die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
finanziell stabilisiert werden kann
erste Beratung erste Lesung dieses
Gesetzentwurfs und jetzt kommt aus den
Ländern ein Vertreter nämlich der
bayerische Minister für Gesundheit und
Pflege Klaus hollitschek frau
Präsidentin hohes Haus lieber Kollege
Lauterbach meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren erstmal will ich feststellen dass
es gut ist dass wir uns heute mal über
die essentiellen Themen unterhalten in
Gesundheit und Pflege immer nicht über
Corona auch noch ein wichtiges Thema
aber jetzt geht es mal an die Substanz
die Themen die die Menschen bewegen wie
finanzieren wir das System wir könnten
heute auch über Pflegeversicherung
sprechen auch ein Desaster wir könnten
über Krankenhausfinanzierung sprechen
auch noch nicht weiter über
sektorenübergreifende Versorgung auch
noch nichts gehört alles Themen die
wichtige und wichtig sind stattdessen
legen Sie heute ein Gesetz vor unter dem
Titel
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz wissen Sie
was das ist es ist ein
versorgungsdestabilisierungsgesetz und
eigentlich hätte der Finanzminister des
einbringen müssen und nicht sicher
Kollege Lauterbach weil die Wahrheit ist
doch das Gesundheitspolitik inzwischen
entweder vom Justizminister oder vom
Finanzminister gemacht das ist keine
Probleme sondern ist meine Erfahrungen
auch aus den Diskussionen in der
Gesundheitsministerkonferenz wo zum
Schluss immer der Satz kommt muss man
schauen was der Herr Lindner dazu sagt
das ist ein eine Kapitulation wenn
Gesundheitspolitik nicht mehr von den
Gesundheitspolitikern gemacht wird
und natürlich wissen wir dass die GKV
die Basis des Gesundheitssystems ist und
wir wissen dass wir im Moment in
schwierigen Zeiten sind Inflation
Energiekosten und wenn die Beiträge
steigen ist das kein gutes Signal für
die Menschen in unserem Land vor diesen
schweren Winter der uns vorsteht sie
steuern auf einen Kassen Crash zu auf
einem Blackout der Versorgung wenn sie
so weitermachen und dann nützt es nichts
wenn Sie ankündigen wir werden dann was
vorlegen jetzt müssen sie vorlegen jetzt
müssen sie es machen
und es steht ja auch in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag drin dass die Beiträge
Arbeitslosengeld zwei Versicherungen
auskömmlich sein sollen wir reden davon
10 Milliarden Euro also es muss hier was
passieren und es darf nicht bei einer
Ankündigung bleiben dass man das
irgendwann tut und irgendwann macht die
zwei Milliarden Bundeszuschuss sind da
einfach viel zu wenig auch die
Dynamisierung des Zuschusses ist
notwendig und richtig und sie sehen doch
die Krankenkassen werden abgeschöpft das
ist kontraproduktiv erst hören dann
stören das ist ein wichtiger Satz der
gilt überall
im bayerischen Landesparlament aber auch
im Deutschen Bundestag den ich selber
mal angehörte von 98 bis 2002 also wir
wissen dass das Abschaffen der
krankenkassenreserven der falsche Weg
ist meine Damen und Herren wenn ich
heute lest das sogar ihr Projekt des
gesundheitskiosk jetzt von den Kasse
nicht mehr finanziert wird weil sie
sehen dass die Politik diese machen den
falschen Weg beschreitert dann sollte
Ihnen das schon zu denken geben lieber
Kollege
und wir wissen noch dass die
Steigerungen weitergehen wenn ich jetzt
sehe durch die richtige und wichtige
Aufnahme der ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
aber in das Leistungssystem die
Überführung wird noch mal eine Milliarde
an Defizit entstehen das kommt noch oben
drauf auf dieses ganze Thema und
deswegen glaube ich stehen wir schon vor
ganz schwierigen Zeiten natürlich wollen
wir zusammenhalten Herr Kollege
Lauterbach das ist unbestritten Länder
und Bund gemeinsam das machen wir in der
GMK auch glaube ich immer deutlich aber
sie setzen nun mal die falschen
Schwerpunkte die Abschaffung der des
Budgets für die neupatientenregelung
wissen Sie was das ist ist eine
Leistungskürzung Herr Kollege lautebach
das können sich schön reden wie sie
wollen
wenn ich alleine die Wartezeiten sehe in
der
Psychotherapeuten Frage in der
versorgungsfreiheit ist es eine
Leistungskürzung reden sie doch nicht
drum rum machen sie sich ehrlich in
diesen Fragen das nützt doch nichts oder
bei den Zahnärzten die
Parodontitis-Therapie ja irre das haben
wir jetzt gerade erst aufgenommen das
geht ja an die Grundversorgung an die
Grundfesten mithin jetzt schaffen wir es
wieder ab
und mit Verlauf des pflegebudget ich
halte das wirklich für einen Irrsinn wir
brauchen in der Pflege jetzt große Würfe
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen wirklich eine
Revolution in der Pflege ich nehme das
Wort nicht oft in den Mund aber es ist
so wir müssen mutig sein und nach vorne
gehen und sie kürzen jetzt das
pflege-budget sie nehmen Leute raus wie
Hebammen zum Beispiel und andere die
nicht mehr refinanziert werden und
schaffen noch mal eine Verschärfung in
diesen wichtigen Bereich statt dass wir
alles tun damit die Pflege spürt wir
stehen hinter ihr Schaffen sie hier
kontraproduktiv genau den falschen Weg
und ich will schon noch was sagen auch
zum Thema Arzneimittel die
pharmabbranche und alle wollen einem
Beitrag leisten darum geht es gar nicht
und die muss nach einem Beitrag leisten
aber wie man das macht ohne den Dialog
Herr Kollege Uhlmann mit den Unternehmen
zu führen ohne einen farmer-dialog
anzustoßen wir werden den innovations-
und Forschungsstandort Deutschland hier
kaputt machen wir feiern ihn für die
Impfstoffe für paxlovit und für
Medikamente und wir machen ihn hier
kaputt weil wissen sie Wirtschaft hat
das mit Vertrauen zu tun und wenn
Unternehmer nicht mehr in die
Rahmenbedingungen vertrauen können dann
werden sie den Standort verlagern und
das ist der Fehler es geht nicht um
einen gerechten Beitrag zu bringen es
geht um die Frage wie man das macht wie
man den Dialog führt und wie man mit
diesen Unternehmen umgeht die Innovation
und Forschung für die Menschen machen es
geht um beste Medizin für die Menschen
und das muss uns bewegen und muss uns
auch gemeinsam nach vorne kommen
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkung aus der FDP-Fraktion von Herrn
Ullmann
ich danke dass Sie die Frage zulassen
wie Sie wissen komme ich aus
Unterfranken und sie kritisieren jetzt
in ausgiebiger Rede die
Fehlentscheidungen der vorhergehenden
Gesundheitsminister die auch
unionsgeführt sind meine Frage konkrete
an sie für uns in Bayern ist die
bayerische Staatsregierung dazu jetzt
bereit auch die Krankenhausfinanzierung
nicht nachzukommen und die Finanzierung
der Krankenhäuser in Bayern
voranzutreiben
außerordentlich dankbar für diese Frage
Bayern investiert 643 Millionen in der
dualen Krankenhausfinanzierung seit 1972
fließen 25 Milliarden in bayerische
Krankenhäusern davon 60% in den
ländlichen Raum jetzt müssen die
Hausaufgaben gemacht werden bei dem
Thema dia cheese das ist nicht unsere
Aufgabe das ist die Aufgabe die hier
passieren muss und da warten wir dass
die Dinge endlich gemacht werden
ich will ihnen nochmal sagen ich glaube
dass die Situation zu explodierenden
Beiträgen führt bei den Kassen
vielleicht sogar zu Schließungen zu
einer weiteren Konzentration Dinge die
nicht gut sind und die schwierig sind
deswegen müssen wir da dagegen steuern
ich würde mir auch wünschen Herr Kollege
Lauterbach dass wir jetzt ein Moratorium
für Bürokratieabbau auf den Weg bringen
auch ein wichtiges und zentrales Thema
wir müssen es tun
ich wäre dass wir das schaffen wenn wir
es jetzt nicht tun und nicht nur darüber
reden und zum Schluss bitte kündigen Sie
dieses Programm jetzt nicht mehr an
machen sie es auch jetzt Energiekosten
Pflege reha-krankenhäuser wir kriegen
einen kalten Strukturwandel im
ländlichen Raum die Krankenhäuser werden
es nicht schaffen 2,8 Milliarden
sachkostensteigerung dieses Jahr 1,7
Millionen Energiekosten das ist nicht
mehr tragbar und wir dürfen nicht mehr
warten jeder Tag ist verloren und die
Pflege ist genauso da wird auch das
Wohngeld nicht reichen das wird nicht
reichen in der Substanz und auch
Reha-Einrichtungen wird zerstören jetzt
Dinge die wir nachher wieder brauchen
denken Sie an long und Bosco wird ihnen
brauche ich das nicht sagen weil sie um
die Bedeutung wissen wenn Reha nicht
mehr funktioniert dann wird auch diese
Struktur nicht mehr da sein sind Sie
mutig setzen Sie sich in der Koalition
durch machen sie Gesundheitspolitik für
die Menschen in unserem Land die haben
es verdient und nach der Pandemie erst
recht
Bayerns Gesundheitsminister Klaus
holletschek in einer Debatte in der es
über das Gesundheitswesen und
Gesundheitspolitik geht schon immer ein
schwieriges Feld über das ich trefflich
streiten lässt und auf denen sich schon
viele Ministerinnen die Zähne
ausgebissen haben an langfristigen
Lösungen schauen wir ganz schnell und
kurz auf die Vorgänger von Karl
Lauterbach Spahn Gröhe Bar Rösler Ulla
Schmidt Andrea Fischer und Horst
Seehofer maria kleinschmaik ist am Pool
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ich muss mal sagen was für ein
Offenbarungseid 16 Jahre unionsgeführter
Gesundheitspolitik die Sie hier
in haben das ist ja nicht zu glauben sie
haben die große klaremauer geführt haben
aber vergessen zu nennen wer eigentlich
verantwortlich ist für das was wir hier
an Krise vorfinden und wir haben
natürlich recht sie haben Recht wir
haben an definitiv von 17 Milliarden
Euro aus ihrer Wahl aus ihrer
Regierungszeit geerbt wir haben geerbt
einen Haushalt der 0 Vorsorge für diese
Deckung der 17 Milliarden Euro
vorgesehen haben sie haben einen
Wahlkampf geführt anders als wir wo sie
jeder Antwort schuldig geblieben sind
wie sie mit diesem Defizit umgehen
wollen jede Antwort wir haben damals
sagt dass wir den Menschen zumuten
werden wir haben gesagt wir werden das
gerecht lösen wir haben aber auch gesagt
es wird teurer werden all das haben sie
nicht getan und zusätzlich haben sie 16
Jahre lang vergessen die großen Krisen
im Gesundheitswesen anzugehen und das
das muss ich mal wirklich sagen
krankenhausreform sie haben sie zu Recht
angesprochen
dieses Problem ist aber nicht neu
sondern es ist ein altbekanntes als ich
2009 hier im Bundestag angekommen bin da
war selbst da das schon ein altbekanntes
Problem wir wissen dass wir es mit
Versäumnissen auf der Länderebene zu tun
haben und wir wissen auch dass wir ein
geldentgeltsystem haben auch Bundesebene
das den Erfordernissen nicht gerecht
wird und deshalb meine Lieben Zuhörer
hier deshalb steht die Reform der
Krankenhausfinanzierung genau jetzt auf
der Tagesordnung wir gehen Sie an wir
haben innerhalb von wenigen Monaten
haben wir Ergebnisse vorlegen wir haben
Vorschläge vorliegen wir werden als
erstes mit der Pädiatrie umgehen wir
werden als zweites mit der Geburtshilfe
umgehen und wir werden insgesamt die
Krankenhausfinanzierung auf eine neue
Grundlage stellen Front 1 frau Klein
tourreform 1
zweiter Schritt wir werden natürlich die
krankenhausreform die ist breiter zu
sehen weil wir haben große
Verschränkungen mit den Ländern
da werden dann an all das was sie jetzt
gerade gesagt haben weil es wird nicht
möglich sein zu sagen wir Bund macht mal
und wir Länder halten mal die Hände auf
weil wir brauchen eine vernunftgeleitete
eine wissenschaftlich fundierte
Krankenhausplanung weit entfernt sind
wir derzeit höchstens in NRW kann man
sagen da gibt es diese Schritte wir
brauchen zusätzlich und da kommt der
zweite Punkt eine Reform der Versorgung
insgesamt integrierte Versorgung
kooperierende Versorgung
Gesundheitszentren die gerade in
ländlichen Räumen uns die Versorgung
sichern können da höre ich von Seiten
der CDU nichts außer die große Klage
dass sie sagen wir brauchen mehr
Hausärzte Frau kleinschmeink ich
versuche schon die ganze Zeit eine Lücke
zu finden um die Frage zu stellen
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkung aus der cdu/csu-fraktion von
Frau Zollner
sehr geehrte Frau Kollegin vielen
herzlichen Dank dass Sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen ich hätte eine
ganz konkrete Frage was tun sie aktuell
um die Krankenhäuser und insgesamt die
soziale Infrastruktur ich denke auch an
die ambulanten Pflegedienste im
ländlichen Raum die mit hohen
Spritkosten umgehen müssen was tun sie
aktuell um dort Entlastungen zu schaffen
bitte ganz konkret was tun sie jetzt
denn jetzt ist dringend Handlung nötig
neben dem sie haben glaube ich den
Minister nicht zugehört und sie haben
auch wahrscheinlich nicht wahrgenommen
dass wir von Seiten der Fraktion
Vorschläge für einen Energie- und
Inflationsschutz hier in dieser Zeit
gemacht haben wir sind in der Diskussion
das wird in den nächsten Wochen
entschieden und da werden wir da werden
wir handeln und ich sag mal eins wir
handeln in dieser Zeit schneller als das
was sie in den ganzen letzten Jahren
gemacht haben und wir werden dafür
sorgen wir werden dafür sorgen dass
Infrastruktur unterstützt wird so
erhalten wird dass wir insgesamt daran
arbeiten können zukunftsgerechte
Lösungen überhaupt erstmal zu erstellen
das ist doch der Punkt gestatten sie
eine weitere Zwischenfrage von der
Fraktion DIE LINKE
gut eine noch
meine Redezeit
ich bin Ihnen ganz besonders dankbar
dass wir auch diese Frage noch mal
zulassen Frau kleinschmank vielen vielen
Dank auch an die Präsidentin ich habe
gerade ihnen zugehört dass sie eine
auskömmliche Finanzierung bei der
Pädiatrie im Geburtshilfe
angehen ich wollte sie an ihren
Koalitionsvertrag erinnern dass da auch
die Notfallversorgung drinsteht und
möchte jetzt fragen weil sie dieser
bewusst oder unbewusst nicht zum ersten
Mal Ausland oder nicht sie sondern die
Korrelation an sich ob sie das Projekt
begraben haben oder ob du das auch noch
angehen werden das werden die Kollegen
und Kollegen der Notfallversorgung
nämlich sehr sehr interessieren ob sie
da zuverlässig sind oder nicht
das ist eine sehr gute Frage weil sie
gibt mir dann die Gelegenheit einen
Eindruck der da vielleicht entstanden
sein könnte richtig zu stellen natürlich
gehen wir gerade auch die
Notfallversorgung an das ist der dritte
Punkt den wir als erstes innerhalb der
großen Reform ja angekündigt haben und
jetzt auch angehen werden sie können
sicher sein genau das werden wir tun so
und jetzt kommen wir doch mal dahin was
sind denn eigentlich die Antworten für
die Zukunft wir werden jetzt mit diesem
GKV Finanz
stabilisierungsgesetz können wir nur
einen Übergang schaffen eine einmalige
Lösung weil der Rückgriff auf Reserven
ist nur einmal möglich wir brauchen ganz
klar eine Strukturreform auch bei der
Finanzierung wir haben in der Ampel
wichtige Schritte im
Koalitionsvertrag verankert und auf die
werden wir auch
arbeiten und genau das werden wir tun
und da ist ja auch mal wieder der
springende Punkt sie alle wissen wir
sind jetzt in einer dreifach-krise wir
sind in einer Krise wo wir sehr gut
aufpassen müssen wie viel Belastung
können wir denn eigentlich den einzelnen
Haushalten den einzelnen Versicherten
den Menschen hier im Lande zumuten und
da haben wir einen guten Ausgleich
gefunden zwischen der Belastung über
Anstieg von von Beitragsmitteln wir
haben gleichzeitig hier den den
rücklagenaufbau und wir haben eine
ein effizienzbeitrag den verschiedene
Leistungserbringer bringen werden wir
werden dieses Ziel nicht aus den Augen
verlieren tatsächlich eine Regel
basierte Refinanzierung all der der
Aufgaben und Ausgaben zu zu installieren
wo es um gesamtgesellschaftliche
Aufgaben geht und da sage ich Ihnen mal
eins 16 Jahre lang haben sie genau das
mich angepackt sie haben es auch in der
letzten Wahlperiode nicht angepackt im
Gegenteil im Gegenteil sie haben im
Koalitionsvertrag stehen haben dass sie
die Beiträge für die ALG2 beziehenden
anheben werden also steuerfinanziert
anheben werden haben sie nicht gemacht
und das in Zeiten mit höchsten Rücklagen
das ist doch der Punkt und dann haben
sie noch was weiteres gemacht sie haben
die Betriebsrentner freigestellt von
höheren Beiträgen und haben das nicht
alle refinanziert gemacht sondern uns in
dieser Wahlperiode ebenfalls
übergeholfen so war ihre Art und Weise
Gesundheitspolitik zu machen und da kann
ich nur sagen dass Erbe von der
Ära Jens Spahn war ein sehr sehr teures
und wir gehen das jetzt an und da können
Sie sicher sein und es ist auch ganz
klar
2024 werden wir weitere Schritte gehen
müssen Richtung gerecht dafür
Finanzierung stabiler und
regelgeleiteter gkv-beiträge das werden
wir angehen und das werden da können Sie
sicher sein und da werden wir eben
unseren Beitrag tatsächlich leisten die
Verantwortung für ein stabiles
Gesundheitswesen zu übernehmen das genau
haben sie nicht getan
Maria klein schmalk aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen wo sie
stellvertretende Vorsitzende ist und ich
glaube einen Punkt können wir hier schon
mal festhalten das was Karl Lauterbach
der
Gesundheitsminister in seiner Rede
gesagt hat dass man versuche hier
gemeinsam zu einer Lösung zu kommen ohne
gegenseitige Schuldzuweisungen das
scheint mir dann doch ein wenig verpufft
in dieser Debatte Martin sichert ist ein
Pult gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher der
afd-fraktion und Jens Spahn musste den
Platz auf der Länderbank wieder frei
machen
die Zeit nehmen wir uns dass wir auch
für die bundesratsbank noch mal das
Prozedere erklären dass hier im Hause
nicht fotografiert wird
so und jetzt hat Herr sichert das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
kürzlich traf ich im friesischen Dangast
eine Frau die mit Tränen in den Augen
vor dem Schwimmbad stand diese Frau
weinte weil sie es sich finanziell
schlicht nicht leisten kann mit ihren
Kindern ins Schwimmbad zu gehen während
Ukrainer kostenlosen Eintritt haben
dieses Beispiel zeigt exemplarisch was
in Deutschland schief läuft während
ukrainische Nobelkarossen vor deutschen
Zahnarztpraxen stehen und nur keiner
sich auf Kosten der deutschen
Beitragszahlen die Zähne richten lassen
wissen viele Deutsche nicht mehr wie sie
angesichts der gestiegenen
Lebenshaltungskosten selbst ihre
Grundnahrungsmittel finanzieren sollen
dass die Ukrainer diese Leistungen
annehmen das kann man ihnen nicht
vorwerfen der Fehler liegt einzig und
allein bei der deutschen Regierung die
auf dem Rücken der einheimischen
Bevölkerung Ausländern ein kostenloses
rundum Sorglos-Paket anbietet dass ein
Ukrainer der mit der Mercedes S-Klasse
vorfährt mehr staatliche Unterstützung
bekommt als eine deutsche
alleinerziehende Mutter ist irre dass
jemand der nicht arbeiten geht
finanziell besser dasteht als jemand der
Vollzeit arbeitet ist irre dass man
wegen angeblicher Überlastung der
Krankenhäuser die Menschen zur Maske
zwingt und zum Impfen nötigt aber
zugleich zulässt dass zahllosen
Krankenhäusern wegen der Energiekosten
die Insolvenz droht ist irre diese
gesamte Politik ist irre
sie weigern sich beharrlich die Ursachen
der Probleme anzugehen die einzige
Lösung die sie kennen ist immer mehr
Geld der Steuerzahler um zu verteilen
sie treiben damit das Land in die
Inflation und die Bürger massenhaft in
die Armut schlimmer noch sie bestrafen
konsequent Leistung genauso wie sie mit
dem Bürgergeld jeden bestrafen der
fleißig ist und arbeiten geht bestrafen
Sie mit diesem Gesetz alle Krankenkassen
die solide gewirtschaftet haben sie
nennen das stabilisierungsgesetz aber in
Wahrheit destabilisieren sie die Kassen
indem sie die vorhandenen Reserven
einiger Kassen sozialistisch umverteilen
sie sind leistungsfeindliche Sozialisten
wer anständig und vernünftig arbeitet
der ist bei ihnen der Dumme und die FDP
die präsentiert sich hier einmal mehr
als reiner Alibi Wurmfortsatz für
rot-grüne Spinnereien sie machen
inzwischen alles mit und haben jede
Position diesmal im Wahlkampf vertreten
haben vollkommen aufgegeben
neben der Massenverarmung der
Bevölkerung durch immer mehr Inflation
und staatliche Umverteilung sehen sie
auch der Zerstörung des deutschen
Gesundheitswesens tatenlos zu zahllosen
Krankenhäusern Reha-Einrichtungen
Physiotherapeuten droht durch die
gestiegenen Energiekosten und die
Inflation die Insolvenz sie reden hier
von Stabilisierung zur wirklich
notwendigen Stabilisierung im
Gesundheitswesen legen sie aber
keinerlei Ansatz vor das ist absolut
unverantwortlich
mit ihrer Politik haben Sie alles in
Schieflage gebracht es ist höchste Zeit
Deutschland wieder vom Kopf auf die Füße
zu stellen hören wir auf jedem illegal
eingereisten und jedem Ukraine ein
Rundum-Sorglos-Paket zum Nulltarif zur
Verfügung zu stellen beenden wir den
Grünen extremistischen Wahnsinn der sich
Energiewende nennt und sorgen wir für
bezahlbare Energie für jedermann und
sorgen wir für allzeit verfügbare und
bezahlbare Arzneimittel indem wir die
Produktion in Deutschland und Europa
stärken das wäre vernünftig und gut und
das wäre Ursachenbekämpfung
[Applaus]
hier hier vorgelegtes Gedankengut des
leistungsfeindlichen Sozialismus ist das
leider nicht
übrigens die eingangs erwähnte
alleinerziehende Mutter wählt in zwei
Wochen bei der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen AFD weil wir als einzige
eine vernünftige Politik vertreten wie
sie in über 90 Prozent der Länder
weltweit normal ist ich hoffe das machen
viele Menschen vielleicht kommen sie
dann mal zum Nachdenken herzlichen Dank
Martin sichert aus der afd-fraktion mit
einer na sagen wir mal sehr besonderen
Sicht auf Ukrainerinnen die sich derzeit
in Deutschland aufhalten aufhalten
müssen sollte man vielleicht ergänzen
Andrew Ullmann ist der nächste Redner
aus der FDP-Fraktion
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren es ist gut dass in der
letzten Bundesregierung Olaf Scholz für
die Staatsfinanzen zuständig war und
nicht jemand aus der Union sonst sehe
unser Bundeshaushalt so aus wie die
gkv-finanzen wir Studenten vor einem
Scherbenhaufen
muss klar zu sagen
dieses Gesetz brauchen wir auch keine
Freude es ist keine Freude nämlich
höhere Zusatzbeiträge zu erheben ist es
kein gutes Gefühl zu Leistungserbringer
zu gehen und zu sagen dass wir trotz
ihrer hochwertig erbrachten medizinische
Leistungen Einsparungen vornehmen müssen
aber was ist die Alternative
ohne ein Gesetz wie dieses würden die
beitragszahlerinnen und Zahler im
kommenden Jahr Beitragssteigerungen von
mehrere hundert Euro erleben
es ist nicht verantwortbar und so etwas
ist die verantwortbar in Zeiten von
Inflation und Energiekrise
es ist daher richtig dass wir die
Finanzierungslücke von 17 Milliarden
Euro im kommenden Jahr nun angehen eine
Zahl die uns nicht überrascht und seit
einiger Zeit im Raume steht der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat erste gute
Vorschläge unterbreitet und ich bedanke
mich auch an dieser Stelle ausdrücklich
bei unserem Finanzminister der ist der
is eine Erhöhung des Bundeszuschusses
trotz der sehr angespannten
Haushaltslage zugestimmt hat
zudem bin ich auch froh dass die
geplante rückwirkend erhobene Solidar
Beitrag für pharmazeutische Unternehmen
im Kabinettsbeschluss sich nicht mehr
wiederfindet bei dieser Regelung halte
ich ordnungspolitische Bedenken
angemeldet es ist gut dass die
Bundesregierung das überarbeitet hat
zudem ist es mir auch wichtig dass wir
von der FDP im vorliegenden Entwurf den
Antrag zu Strukturreformen im
Gesundheitswesen gesetzlich verankert
haben die Defizite in der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung werden in den
kommenden Jahren nicht weniger aufgrund
der Alterung der Gesellschaft und der
angespannten wirtschaftlichen Situation
werden die Einnahmen voraussichtlich
geringer und die Ausgaben werden weiter
steigen ja meine Damen und Herren
tatsächlich eine
ausgabenpublik ein Ausgabenproblem denn
die Fehlanreize im Gesundheitssystem
sorgen für ein teures aber wenig
effizientes System
[Applaus]
da müssen wir gemeinsam an die
Strukturen ran um die Kosten im Griff zu
behalten
es geht bei dieser Entwicklung das große
Ganze es geht darum ob eine
Krankenversicherung dessen
Leistungsspektrum staatlich organisiert
wird funktionieren kann die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung steht vor allem
wegen dem politischen Management
schlechter da als die private
Krankenversicherung
die private Krankenversicherung Dingen
mit ihrem Finanzierungssystem mit der
Bildung von Rücklagen an die Zukunft
die Umlagefinanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenkasse ist in Zeiten des
demografischen Wandels nicht mehr auf
der Höhe der Zeit ich halte es trotzdem
für unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe die
Zukunft der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung zu sichern dafür ist
dieses Gesetz ein erster Schritt aber
sicherlich meine Damen und Herren nicht
der letzte
dabei geht es nicht nur um
Strukturreformen innerhalb des
Abrechnungssystems sollen reformsysteme
die die cdu/csu nicht getraut haben in
den Jahren der Regierungszeit anzugehen
unsere forschungskoalition in der Ampel
hat uns ambitionierte Ziele gesetzt
Ziele die ein dringlicher Umsetzung
bedürfen denn anders werden unsere
Erwartungen in ein gutes
Gesundheitssystem scheitern
meine Damen und Herren unser
Gesundheitssystem muss menschlicher
digitaler ambulanter vernetzter
bedarfsgerechter und innovativer werden
und für die Leistungserbringer wird das
System auskömmlich finanziert sein das
GKV finanzstabilisierungsgesetz ist ein
erster notwendiger aber schmerzlicher
Schritt doch die nächsten wichtigen
Reformschritte sind bereits
vorgezeichnet so machen wir unser
Gesundheitssystem resilienter und
zukunftssicher für alle und ich freue
mich auf die Diskussion in unserem
Ausschuss herzlichen Dank
Andrew Ullmann aus der FDP-Fraktion wo
er gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher ist
und ihm folgt jetzt arktisch Göppinger
aus der Linksfraktion da ist ja Sprecher
für Krankenhaus und pflegepolitik
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren sehr geehrter
Herr Minister sie haben gesagt wir
sollten nicht polemisch werden ich darf
irgendwie daran erinnern dass sie mit
der Politik angefangen haben indem sie
das Gesetz finanzstabilisierungsgesetz
genannt haben ich glaube das ist die
erste Politik die wir wie sie sich
geleistet haben und müssen mit manchen
leider auch üblen Reaktionen dann
rechnen ich möchte anfangen mit dem
Problem der Schätzung das erste von sie
ausgehen sie sagen es geht um 17
Milliarden Euro dem nächsten Jahr fehlen
werden ich möchte daran erinnern dass
das sehr niedrig gerechnet ist es gibt
andere berechnungsinstitut für
Gesundheit und Sozialforschung hat von
24,6 Milliarden Euro ist von 24,6
Milliarden Euro ausgegangen und das war
im Juni diesen Jahres da war sozusagen
die Kosten hier im Winter auf die ganzen
leistungsbringerinnen der Bringer
zukommen noch gar nicht drin die ganzen
Krankenhäuser Pflege die quasi von den
die sehr energiekostenreich sind und die
ganzen Energiekosten tragen müssen
diesen da noch gar nicht berücksichtigt
deswegen sind die 17 Milliarden
definitiv zu wenig diese Zahlen werden
nicht ausreichen und deswegen ist das
was sie da beschreiben Polemik weil sie
schon vom viel zu geringen Betrag
ausgehen den sie nächstes Jahr
ausgleichen müssen
und das Problem ist aber was ihr gerade
benannt haben wie das Ganze stabilisiert
werden soll sie behaupten die ganze Zeit
das kommt eben nicht so sehr auf die
beitragszahlerinnen Beitragszahler zu
der Spitzenverband der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung sieht das anders der
geht von 11 von diesen 17 Milliarden
Euro aus der eigentlich bei den
Beitragszahlen landet landet warum zum
einen die Anhebung und von Ihnen
genannten 0,3 Prozent sind in diesem
Winter übrigens schon eine beachtliche
Summe weil es nicht das einzige ist was
auf die Menschen zukommt und ich darf
nur mal daran erinnern dass die
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung vor
allem von den mittelverdienenden und
geringverdienen geleistet werden weil
die höherverdienen dort gar nicht
einzahlen unter anderem auch einige von
ihnen nicht das heißt also das geht vor
allem an den an an ans Geld die jetzt
schon nur noch allzu wenig haben das
eigentliche Problem ist aber und das
wird dann wirklich absurd dass sie
selbst beschreiben dass die Lasten auf
verschiedenen Schultern verteilt werden
müssen und nicht ich zitiere allein den
beitragszahlerinnen und Beitragszahler
auferlegt werden können und dann
schreiben so sind auf der Einnahmenseite
neben höheren Bundesmitteln auch die
Finanzreserven der Krankenkassen
hinzuzuziehen nun möchte ich Sie fragen
wie die Reserven eigentlich woher die
Reserven dieser Krankenkassen eigentlich
kommen wenn nicht von den
beitragszahlenden Herr Lauterbach die
haben diese Reserven nämlich mit
aufgebaut und deswegen ist der
Spitzenverband der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung richtig in der
Ansicht zu sagen dass 11 von 17
Milliarden von den gesetzlich
Versicherten geleistet werden direkt
oder indirekt nun könnten wir eine große
Lösung vorschlagen endlich eine
solidarische Gesundheitsversicherung zu
machen das wäre dringend nötig sie
schreiben ja auch ganz schön dass es
alles solidarisch geleitet werden soll
auch wenn sie selbst nicht tun
wir haben auch eine kleine Lösung
vorgeschlagen die sie jetzt angehen
könnten die sie einfach übernehmen
könnten wir haben Anträge eingereicht
die weitaus mehr Geld zur Verfügung
stehen würden wenn sie das annehmen
würden dass das was sie vorschlagen zum
einen wollen wir die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze nicht sofort
auflösen das natürlich unser Ziel
sondern zunächst mal Anhebung anheben
auf das Niveau der Rentenversicherung
West das heißt es gibt eine Anhebung des
betrifft dann nicht ihre Geringverdiener
die mehr zahlen müssen das betrifft er
nicht die mittelverdienenden die jetzt
im Winter schon nicht mehr für die
Runden kommen sondern das betrifft
tatsächlich diejenigen die jetzt gut
verdienen das Punkt eins das wären 12,65
Milliarden Euro dieser mit mehr in der
Tasche hätten das wäre das eine der
zweite Punkt und ich bin ja glaube ich
selten in der Holidaycheck auch obwohl
auch aus Bayern aber da einer Meinung
warum sie die Beitragszahlungen der ALG2
beziehenden durch den Bund nicht
reformieren das werden weitere 2,6
Milliarden Euro um dies jetzt gehen
würde das können Sie jetzt
und drittens wir reden ja auch von der
Reduzierung der Mehrwertsteuer das hat
er nicht immer Sinn gemacht wenn wir
beiden Arzneimittel aber den mäßigten
Mehrwertsteuersatz anwenden würden dann
wäre das weil es ein sehr stark
regulierter Markt wäre tatsächlich etwas
was bei den Erbringern ankommen würde
das wären weitere 5 Milliarden Euro all
das haben wir einen Anträgen vorgelegt
setzen die sie um dann wird es auch
weniger polemisch wenn sie den Titel von
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz nicht wird
dann müssen den Titel
finanzstabilisierung jetzt nicht mehr
ändern um selbst nicht polemisch zu sein
vielen vielen Dank
hinaus der Linksfraktion Krankenhaus und
pflegepolitischer Sprecher und jetzt
kommt für die SPD Christos pantazis dr
med übrigens der neurobionik und wenn
sie jetzt Fragezeichen im Gesicht haben
muss ich sie mit den kurz alleine lassen
und Kollegen eine Krise jagt die nächste
selten hat eine Redewendung unsere Zeit
so treffend beschrieben wie diese
corona-pandemie Klimawandel und nicht
zuletzt der russische Angriffskrieg mit
drastisch gestiegenen Energiepreisen und
Ton Inflationsraten haben zu einem
Konjunktureinbruch in Deutschland
geführt diese Entwicklung setzt sich
auch die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
unter Druck seit Jahren wachsen hier die
Ausgaben mit jährlich rund vier
Prozentpunkten spürbar stärker als die
Einnahmen wesentlicher Grund dafür ist
ein anhaltender Reformstau infolgedessen
sehen wir uns mit einer
milliardenschweren Defizit konfrontiert
das allein im nächsten Jahr 17
Milliarden Euro betragen soll 17
Milliarden das ist genau die Zahl des
Tages über die wir im Rahmen des
heutigen ersten Lesung des
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetzes
beraten und die es im kommenden Jahr
kurzfristig zu schließen gilt
Herr Minister ich will in diesem
Zusammenhang nicht verhehlen dass ich es
ihnen hoch anrechne ihren Amtsvorgänger
hierfür nicht zu kritisieren aber zur
Wahrheit gehört auch ihr Vorgänger im
Amt hat seine Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
und Ihnen dieses Defizit sprichwörtlich
vererbt
ihr Vorgänger im Amt hat es trotz
wirtschaftlich guter Rahmenbedingungen
nicht vermocht Strukturreform
entschieden anzugehen sondern sich viel
mehr auf populäre allerdings teure
leistungsreform konzentriert die uns
jetzt auf die Füße fallen deswegen
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union wird das gelinde gesagt etwas
wohlfall nun aus der Position heraus
welche Mensch Strukturreform
einzufordern und nach Jahren der
Blockade sich unser nachhaltigen
finanzierungsvorschlägen anzueignen
Pferdekollegen Kollegen obwohl wir die
Finanzen der gesetzlichen Krankenkassen
in einem sehr schwierigen Zustand
vorgefunden haben es ist ja vorhin eben
gerade auch schon erläutert worden
bekennt sich die forschungskoalition
auch weiterhin ich zitiere gerne aus der
Koalitionsvereinbarung zu einer stabilen
und verlässlichen Finanzierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
das von der Bundesregierung hier
vorgelegte GKV
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz begrüßen wir
von der Stoßrichtung her denn ohne
kurzfristig greifende Maßnahmen müssen
die Zusatzbeiträge im kommenden Jahren
von derzeit durchschnittlich 1,3 Prozent
um rund ein Prozent steigen in
Anbetracht ansteigender Energiepreise
sowie hoher Inflationsraten wäre das für
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
schlichtweg Gift und könnte für private
Haushalte womöglich die Grenze der
Belastbarkeit beschreiben insofern sieht
der vorliegende Gesetzentwurf vor die
Lasten solidarisch auf mehrere Schultern
zu verteilen so sollen beitragsreserven
von Kassen und Gesundheitsfond
herangezogen aber auch ein erhöhter
Bundeszuschuss sowie Italiener die GKV
gewährt werden im Rahmen von
Effizienzverbesserung werden neben der
Pharmaindustrie auch Apotheken
Zahnärztinnen und Ärztinnen ihren
Beitrag zur Stabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung leisten
müssen diese Lastenverteilung ermöglicht
es Zusatzbeiträge lediglich in einer
moderaten Rahmen in Höhe von 0,3
Prozentpunkten zu erhöhen der hier
vorliegende Entwurf verfolgt also das
Ziel die gkv-finanzen zu stabilisieren
ohne dabei auf Leistungskürzungen
zurückgreifen zu müssen was ich für
meine Fraktion ausdrücklich begrüße
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit
dem mit diesem vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf wird ein kurzfristiger
Ausgleich des Defizits von 17 Milliarden
Euro erreicht die fortschrittskoalition
vertritt allerdings den Anspruch die
gkv-finanzen langfristig verlässlich und
somit krisenfest aufzustellen um diesem
Anspruch gerecht zu werden halten wir
tiefgreifende Strukturreformen
Gesundheitssystem für unumgänglich von
der Krankenhausfinanzierung über die
ambulantisierung bis hin zur
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen in
der Pflege werden wir Reformvorhaben
anhand unserer Koalitionsvereinbarung
sukzessive abarbeiten
denselben Anspruch liegt meine Fraktion
wenn es um die nachhaltige Finanzierung
der GKV geht auch hier werden wir uns an
den Leitplanken des Koalitionsvertrages
orientieren das schließt ausdrücklich
die regelhafte Dynamisierung des
Bundeszuschusses sowie höhere Beiträge
für die Beziehungen und Bezieher von
Arbeitslosengeld 2 aus steuern Mitteln
mit ein
meine Fraktion strebt weiterhin eine
ausgewogene Finanzierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung an
dabei spielt auch die Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze eine gewichtige
Rolle
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
komme zum Schluss das Wesen der
parlamentarischen Demokratie ist der
Kompromiss und in Zeiten wo eine Krise
die nächste Jagd muss der
Parlamentarismus genau hier durch seine
Handlungsfähigkeit unter Beweis stellen
schließlich geht es um nicht weniger als
die zentrale Säule unseres
Solidarsystems die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung diese gilt es zu
stützen und die Lasten dabei gerecht zu
verteilen herzlichen Dank für Ihre
aufmerksam
Christos patatis aus der SPD-Fraktion
und falls Sie es nicht gerade selber
nachgeguckt haben neurobionik ist die
Verbindung von Neurologie Biologie und
Technik geht natürlich auch noch viel
komplizierter aber wir lassen uns mal
dabei Tino Sorge ist ja nicht so Redner
in dieser Debatte er ist
gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion an dem Punkt wo wir
darüber diskutieren wie wir das
gesetzliche Versicherungssystem die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung
zukunftsfest machen können und da bin
ich bin ich jedes mal wieder total
irritiert wenn Sie sich hier aus der
Ampelkoalition insbesondere die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der SPD
hinstellen und so tun als hätten sie die
letzten Jahre hier überhaupt nicht
mitregiert liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen also ich darf nur noch mal dran
erinnern wir waren sie haben 23 Jahre
dieses Land mitregiert 23 Jahre wir
haben in der letzten Legislatur auf
ausdrücklichen Wunsch und gemeinsam auch
auf Kunst von Herrn
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
viele gute Dinge auf den Weg gebracht
ich darf nur an die Verbesserung in der
Pflege erinnern ich darf an die neue
patientenregelung ändern ich darf an die
Verbesserung beim bei der Zahngesundheit
erinnern und das erste was Sie jetzt tun
an Vorschlägen hier zu machen für die
Finanzierung der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung ist diese guten
Regelungen wieder zurückzutreten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und da wundern
sie sich da wundern sie sich allen
Ernstes lieber Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister das unisono
alle Akteure dieses Gesundheitssystems
sagen das geht so nicht ich darf nur mal
zitieren der Vorsitzende des Gemeinsamen
Bundesausschusses der sich ja relativ
selten so deutlich zu Wort
äußert hat gesagt bei diesem
Gesetzentwurf handelt es sich um ein
völlig sinnloses Sammelsurium Zitat
ändern und ich darf noch mal darauf
hinweisen mein Bundesland Sachsen-Anhalt
da haben gestern 20 Akteure des gesamten
Gesundheitssystems von Ärzten
Krankenkassen bis hin zum Deutschen
Gewerkschaftsbund ein gemeinsamer relles
Resolution auf den Weg gebracht in der
sie sagen in dieser Form geht das nicht
das liegt die Axt an die Wurzel unseres
Gesundheit und spätestens da lieber Herr
Kollege Lauterbach liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel sollten bei Ihnen die
Alarmglocken ganz laut schrillen
und deshalb Frau Kollegin kleinschmeich
hören Sie endlich auf sie regieren seit
fast einem Jahr hier kommen nur
Konjunktive Sie möchten Sie werden sie
sollten wo ist denn die Unterstützung
die Soforthilfe für die Kliniken wo ist
denn die Unterstützung wir haben vor der
Sommerpause als Unionsfraktion einen
Antrag vorgelegt indem wir gefordert
haben aufgrund der extrem gestiegenen
energiepreiskosten die Kliniken zu
unterstützen nichts passiert sie treiben
die Kliniken in den Insolvenz und wenn
sie da jetzt nicht zeitnah nachlegen
passiert gar nichts Finanzreform Pflege
auf 2023 verschoben
krankenhauskommission lieber Kollege
Lauterbach wir haben es in den
Kommission eingesetzt die Kommission
wird ein Langzeitprojekt keine
Ergebnisse insofern handeln sie endlich
und kommen sie aus dem ankündigungsmodus
raus liebe Kolleginnen keine Sorge
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage von der
Kollegin klein schmeink
Herr Kollege Tino Sorge sie haben eine
ganze Reihe von Problemen angesprochen
die wir ja alle geerbt haben aus der
letzten Wahlperiode und was haben Sie
denn unternommen um eine grundlegende
krankenhausstrukturreform auf den Weg zu
bringen gemeinsam mit ihrem Kollegen
Herrn Minister holitschek was haben Sie
denn unternommen um zum Beispiel die
ländliche Versorgung tatsächlich zu
stabilisieren und voranzubringen was
haben sie unternommen um die
Zusammenarbeit zwischen den
Gesundheitsberufen so zu stärken dass
wir auch tatsächlich nach vorne
gerichtet die Versorgung sicherstellen
können Sie zählen hier viele Dinge auf
haben an ganz vielen Punkten
beispielsweise auch nicht gesagt wie
finanzieren Sie das denn jetzt und das
würde ich ganz gerne von Ihnen hören
erstens warum hat es diese grundlegende
Krankenhaus
im Zusammenspiel mit den Ländern bisher
nicht gegeben zweitens was tun sie
bezogen auf die Zusammenarbeit der
Gesundheitsberufe was haben sie da getan
was wirklich voranbringt und drittens
wie finanzieren Sie genau diese Lücke
sie klagen halt hier jetzt nur darüber
aber was machen Sie denn ganz konkret
zur Refinanzierung ich habe noch nichts
Schriftliches von ihnen gesehen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin kleinschweig
das gibt mir die Möglichkeit noch mal
detailliert auf die ganzen
Gesetzesvorhaben die wir in den letzten
Legislaturen gemacht haben auf den Weg
auf den Weg nicht nur zu bringen sondern
ihn noch mal zu erklären sie waren ja
offensichtlich häufig nicht da wir haben
erstens in der Pflege Pflegeberufe
reformgesetzt wir haben die Ausbildung
in der Pflege reformiert wir haben die
Leistung für Pflegebedürftige für die
Angehörige reformiert wir haben in einem
großen gesellschaftlichen Konsens
zusätzlich Geld ins System gegeben haben
erstmals für Alzheimer erkrankte
beispielsweise dass sie überhaupt
erstmal Anspruch auf Pflegeleistung
haben immer wir im Krankenhausbereich
Krankenhaus Zukunftsfonds Milliarden auf
den Weg gebracht damit Digitalisierung
vorangetrieben wird wir haben drei große
digitalisierungsgesetz gemacht ich frage
mich wo sie in der Zeit hier waren wenn
das alles an ihm vorbeigegangen liebe
Frau Kollegin
und jetzt jetzt hören Sie jetzt hören
Sie endlich auf immer so zu tun als
hätten sie nie politische Verantwortung
getragen das ist ja in jedem Bereich
mittlerweile so dass sie so tun als
hätten sie nie hier irgendwie im
Bundestag gesessen sie müssen endlich
auch mal pragmatisch jetzt Lösung
vorlegen und nicht immer nur ankündigen
und sagen sie werden sie wollen und Sie
möchten und ich sage Ihnen auch ganz
klar wenn sie dann schon Vorschläge
vorlegen dann tun sie doch wenigstens
das was im Koalitionsvertrag schreiben
da schreiben sie ja durchaus an der ein
oder anderen Stelle gute Sachen das ist
angesprochen worden zehn Milliarden
würde das System entlastet werden wenn
sie erstmal in der richtigen Höhe die
Beiträge für ALG2 Bezieher abführen
würden es gibt eine Menge Vorschläge
aber jetzt die neue patientenregelung
zurückzudrehen wo Patienten viel
schneller das erste Mal Termin beim
Facharzt bekommen haben die sich jetzt
beschweren wo die Ärzte sagen sie haben
Personal eingestellt was sie wieder
entlassen müssten hören Sie doch auf
dieser Regelung zurückzutreten die eher
marginale Summen einsparen sondern gehen
Sie die strukturellen Probleme an liebe
Frau Kollegin klein Liebe ampelqualition
und deshalb recht es sich jetzt dass ich
der Bundesgesundheitsminister der
Bundesfinanzminister der
Bundesjustizminister nicht über den Weg
trauen klaus holletschek hat sie
angesprochen es kann doch nicht sein
dass der Bundesgesundheitsminister jedes
Mal bei jedem strukturellen Vorhaben
sagt ich muss da erstmal Christian
Lindner Fragen und der dann sagt ich
habe das mit Karl Lauterbach ganz anders
besprochen das ist doch die bankrotte
Erklärung für Gesundheitspolitik in
diesem Land
und deshalb sage ich Ihnen ganz klar
machen sie nicht solche Murks wie bei
der gasumlage denken Sie jetzt schnell
an die Kliniken sonst gehen viele
Kliniken im Herbst in die Insolvenz das
wird zu Versorgungsengpässen führen das
haben die Patienten nicht verdient das
haben die Leistungserbringer nicht
verdient und vor allen Dingen noch ein
Wort zum Schluss lieber Herr Kollege
Lauterbach wenn sie schon mit vielen
Worten den Akteuren im System danken
wenn sie sagen Danke liebe Ärzte danke
Apotheker danke Pflegekräfte dass wir
mit euch so gut durch diese Pandemie
gekommen sind vielen Dank innovative
Pharmaindustrie dann ist es für diese
Menschen mittlerweile einen hohen wenn
sie als erste Maßnahme dann sagen wir
machen Preismoratorium wir kürzen es
gibt weniger Geld Apothekenabschlag also
diese Leute empfinden das als
Leistungskürzung und hier zu sagen es
gäbe keine Leistungskürzung entspricht
nicht der Wahrheit vielen herzlichen
Dank
Tino Sorge gesundheitspolitischer
Sprecher der Unionsfraktion hat jetzt
gar nicht erwähnt die Vorschläge seines
Fraktionskollegen Sepp Müller der ja
eingeregt hatte die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze anzuheben sowie
die Versicherungspflichtgrenze das würde
bedeuten dass die berühmten stärkeren
Schulter auch stärker beteiligt wären an
den Einnahmen der Krankenkassen jetzt
Janosch Damen für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen
anderweitig zuschauen die Debatte die
wir hier erleben ist von einigen aus
diesem Hause in einem Maße unredlich
geführt was wirklich seinesgleichen
sucht ich muss sagen das eine ist eine
Fehlerkultur hier in den letzten Tagen
hinzulegen die bei jedem Mal wenn es
darum geht was in der Vergangenheit
nicht richtig gelaufen ist mit Gejohle
zu reagieren und einfach so zu tun als
sei es vergessen und nicht den Hauch
einer Demut an den Tag zu legen für
Dinge die falsch gelaufen sind und die
jetzt korrigiert werden müssen das
andere
das andere und das ist viel schlimmer
ist eine Oppositionsarbeit zu betreiben
die offensichtlich sich jeder
Rechenschaft entleert wie denn
Vorschläge mit der Situation die jetzt
nun mal vorzufinden ist umgegangen
werden sollen mit Vorschlägen wie denn
die 17 Milliarden die als Defizit in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung liegen
wie diese aufgelöst werden sollen ich
habe nicht gehört dass aus den
unionsreihen die Aufhebung der
Schuldenbremse gefordert wird ich habe
nicht gehört dass sie fordern dass die
Beiträge für die Menschen in diesem Land
in einem Maße angeheben werden soll die
keiner in diesem Wind da stemmen kann
ich habe nicht gehört dass sie fordern
das Leistungskürzung im Gesundheitswesen
in Ersatz zu diesem Defizit durchgeführt
werden sollen und sich einfach
hinzustellen ohne ein Hauch eines
Vorschlags zu sagen wie das Defizit
aufgelöst werden soll das ist bei allen
Fehlern der Vergangenheit heute
unredliche Oppositionsarbeit und ich
muss Ihnen sagen das hätten wir uns
nicht getraut
verdamm gestatten Sie eine Frage oder
Zwischenbemerkung von dem Kollegen Sorge
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
ja vielen Dank lieber Herr Kollege Damen
dass sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen mich
würde ganz konkret interessieren werden
sie das was sie im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben nämlich die zehn
Milliarden an Zahlungen für
alg2-bezieher auch dem Gesundheitssystem
zur Verfügung stellen zeitnah umsetzen
und mich würde vor allen Dingen
interessieren ob Sie der Meinung sind
dass jetzt die Abschmelzung der
kassenreserven ob das da sie ja im
Vorfeld durch die Versicherten
aufgebracht worden sind keine
Leistungskürzung bzw
Beitragssatzerhöhung indirekt darstellen
vielen Dank für die Frage Herr Kollege
Sorge ich will ihnen darauf antworten
also erstens selbstverständlich werden
wir den Koalitionsvertrag umsetzen und
das beinhaltet auch dass wir die
Beiträge für ALG2 versichert in der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung auf das
Notwendige finanzierungsmaß anheben
werden wir werden auch den
Bundeszuschuss dynamisieren um ein
ordnungspolitischen Automatismus da drin
zu haben wie Finanzierung funktioniert
und nicht durch eine Serie an
digitalreform die unstrukturiert ohne
digitalstrategie ein Riesenloch
beispielsweise gerissen haben jetzt mit
dazu beitragen dass wir hier solch ein
Finanzierungsdefizit haben zweiter Punkt
ihrer Frage ich bin nicht der
Überzeugung dass wir in Zeiten Multipla
Krisen irgendwo in der Ecke Reserven
liegen lassen können die wir brauchen um
die Not die in diesem Land Existenz ist
abzufedern insofern ist es richtig jeder
der Beteiligten
Stakeholder im Gesundheitswesen
aufzufordern zu sagen wie können wir
gemeinsam einen Beitrag leisten genau
das tut das Gesetz indem wir eben nicht
sagen es gibt einen der beteiligten
Seiten die alles schultern muss sondern
bei den gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherungen bei den
Krankenhäusern im Bereich der
niedergelassenen Ärzte und der
Krankenversicherung gemeinsam schauen
wie ein Beitrag geleistet werden kann um
das Problem zu beheben das ist
verantwortliche Politik und ich will
ihnen sagen in der Opposition wir sind
immer zu den unseren Haushältern
gegangen und haben die Refinanzierung
von kritikvorschlägen hier im Parlament
vorher abstimmen müssen ich glaube es
war bei der FDP nicht anders und ich
kann sagen so ist verantwortliche
Oppositionsarbeit aber zu Unredlichkeit
Herr Damm ich habe noch eine
Zwischenfrage von der Kollegin Vogler
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin vielen Dank
Herr Kollege dass sie meine
Zwischenfrage zulassen sie haben ja
gerade gesagt dass sie über die
Schuldenbremse diskutieren weil das
finde ich auch sehr sehr wichtig da sind
wir als LINKE voll bei Ihnen die
Schuldenbremse hindert uns daran aber
wir brauchen ja für die Stabilisierung
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
eigentlich keine Sondervermögen zu
erheben sondern wir haben ja ganz
konkrete als konstruktive
Oppositionsfraktion ganz konkrete
Vorschläge auf den Tisch gelegt für die
eigentlich auch eine Mehrheit hier im
Hause möglich wäre sowohl Maria
kleinschmain von ihrer Fraktion
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
als auch der Kollege brandharzis von der
SPD als auch sogar der stellvertretende
unionsfraktionsvorsitzende Sepp Müller
haben ja genau das gefordert was wir in
unserem Antrag zur Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze und der
Pflichtversicherungsgrenze fordern und
ich frage mich dann schon wie lange
wollen wir uns hier die offensichtlich
eine politische Mehrheit hätten um diese
sehr gute Idee umzusetzen die
tatsächlich das leisten kann was Karl
Lauterbach ja gefordert hat nämlich
starke Schultern mehr tragen zu lassen
als schwache wenn wir diese Möglichkeit
haben warum kämpfen wir nicht darum
dafür auch hier eine parlamentarische
Mehrheit zu bekommen statt uns vom
Förderverein der
privatversicherungsunternehmen auch
vulgo FDP
hier an der Nase herumführen zu lassen
vielen dank vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Vogler zunächst mal möchte ich Ihnen und
Ihrer Fraktion zu gut erhalten dass sie
im Gegensatz zur Union konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht haben was man denn
tun kann denn gleich auch die Frage der
refinanzierbarkeit nicht in all den
Vorschlägen hinterlegt ist will ich doch
wohl sagen dass wir wie eben angedeutet
selbstverständlich im Verlauf der
Legislatur weitergehende umfassendere
strukturelle Reformen im Bereich der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
einschließlich der Diskussion Anhebung
der ALG2 Sätze Dynamisierung
Bundeszuschuss und auch der Frage der
Anhebung der
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze miteinander
beraten und auch beschließen werden
insofern zu sagen dass diese Reform das
letzte und abschließende Wort zur
Weiterentwicklung und Stabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung ist
wäre falsch und insofern begreifen sie
dies als einen ersten Schritt der von
weiteren sehr viel umfassenden Reformen
im kommenden Jahr gefolgt werden wird
lassen Sie mich fortfahren
beim Thema Unredlichkeit kann ich es mir
nicht verkneifen einmal auf den
bayerischen Gesundheitsminister
holitschek reagieren zu müssen ich muss
schon sagen dass sie sich hier
hinstellen und so tun als hätten wir
nicht ekla ein eklatantes Problem im
Bereich der Investitionskosten
Finanzierung überall und auch
ausdrücklich in Bayern da gehört schon
einiges dazu das wissen sie doch alle in
Verantwortung in den Ländern
beispielsweise bei ihnen in Bayern ist
es nicht so dass sie sich hier
hinstellen können und einfach eine Zahl
mit sechs Stellen hier in den Raum
werfen damit das so klingt als sei das
viel wenn es faktisch mit dem realen
Wertverlust doch bedeutet dass sie seit
1991 40 Prozent weniger
Investitionskosten im Bereich ihrer
Krankenhauslandschaft ausgegeben haben
und hat das was mit unserer realen
Situation jetzt zu tun na
selbstverständlich die fehlenden
Investitionskosten führen dazu dass
jedes Krankenhausbett bei ihnen in
Bayern so viel Energie verbraucht wie
ein Einfamilienhaus mit meiner ganzen
fünfköpfigen Familie das führt dazu dass
die Not der Kliniken im Moment so groß
ist dass die Kosten so stark steigen und
dass wir jenseits dieses Gesetzes
selbstverständlich weitere
Rettungsmaßnahmen für die stationäre
Versorgung auf den Weg bringen müssen
und jetzt zu sagen jetzt zu sagen dass
nicht in einem einzigen Gesetz die
gesamten Probleme der Gesundheitspolitik
aufgelöst werden ja was ist denn das für
ein Politikverständnis immer nur zu
zeigen der moment mal hier liegt ein
Vorschlag vor aber es gibt auch noch
andere Probleme zu denen ist nichts
gesagt worden das ist doch keine Politik
das ist doch einfach nur marktschreierei
und Ablenkung gehen Sie doch auf die
Vorschläge ein bringen sie Alternativen
ein sagen Sie dieses refinanzieren
wollen und sind sie ehrlich zu den
Menschen erzählen sie nicht vor einer
Wahl es gibt kein Problem wenn 17
Milliarden fehlen sondern sagen Sie was
bedeutet das und inzwischen haben wir
multiple Krisen auf die wir reagieren
müssen und ich will Ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen wir tun wir tun das sehr
verantwortungsvoll indem wir mit allen
Seiten sprechen dass jeder zunächst mal
sagt ich kann nichts geben weil wird bei
mir groß ist ist doch selbstverständlich
in diesen Zeiten das heißt aber nicht
dass wir uns nicht alle zusammenstehen
müssen in Beitrag leisten das liefert
das Gesetz und zum Rettungsschirm ja wir
werden zum Thema Energiekosten Ausgleich
für Kliniken und Pflegeversorgung was
tun ja wir müssen bei der bei der
inflationsbremse im Gesundheitswesen
ansetzen und werden auf die Länder
zukommen und sie beim Wort nehmen dass
wir das gemeinsam schultern und ja auch
Strukturreform sind mit der
krankenhauskommission auf den Weg
gebracht werden hier eingebracht werden
und das wirklich 16 Jahre verfehlte
Politik nicht in 16 Monaten aufgelöst
sind was ist das für ein glaube das ist
einfach wirklich unredliche Opposition
und ich finde da haben die noch eine
Menge nachzuholen wir gehen hier
wirklich die Probleme an und sind für
ernstgemeinte Vorschläge geht gerne
offen und werden sie im
parlamentarischen Verfahren gerne
gemeinsam beraten
der gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen vor
seiner Zeit im Parlament war er
medizinaldirektor und Oberarzt in der
ärztlichen Leitung des Rettungsdienst
Berlin für die Berliner Feuerwehren
nächster Redner Jörg Schneider AFD
Arzneimittel versorgen da geht es unter
anderem Grippe Impfstoffe sie sehen hier
einen erhöhten Bedarf und da sollten wir
doch vielleicht mal fragen wo kommt der
eigentlich her seit zweieinhalb Jahren
schüren sie Corona engst und das hört ja
nicht auf wird des Herrn Ministers eine
verunglückte Desinformationskampagne und
das verfängt viele Menschen vermeiden
bis heute soziale Kontakte verlassen die
eigene Wohnung nur mit einer Maske vor
dem Gesicht und das ist ein Problem denn
soziale Kontakte ohne Maske das sorgt
dafür dass das Immunsystem einer
gewissen Belastung ausgesetzt wird das
ist trainiert wird und dieses Training
fehlt vielen Menschen
dieses Training führt vielen Menschen
und
meine Partei hat darauf relativ früh
reagiert wir haben gefordert dass wir zu
Normalität zurückkehren das haben sie
abgelehnt sie wollen jetzt mehr impfen
einmal mehr lösen Sie also mit
erheblichen finanziellen Aufwand ein
Problem dass wir ohne ihre Politik
überhaupt nicht hätten meine Damen und
Herren
eine Aspekt ein Aspekt der
Arzneimittelversorgung sind
Lieferengpässe das hängt vor allen
Dingen mit den Produktionsstandorten
zusammen die liegen nämlich in Indien
und China China fährt gerade mit einer
irrensirokowit-politik die Lieferketten
vor die Wand und das wird sich in
Zukunft nicht besser die Inder haben
zwar gerne die 10 Milliarden Euro
Entwicklungshilfe angenommen die sie den
hinterher geworfen haben orientieren
sich aber mehr in Richtung Russland
zuverlässige Lieferanten sind das für
mich nicht und dabei haben sie in der
großen Koalition eigentlich ganz
vernünftig angefangen im
Koalitionsvertrag steht dass sie eine
Rückverlagerung der Produktion von
Arzneimitteln zu uns wünschen ich darf
Sie dafür loben weil das eine alte Idee
der AFD ist wie sie da übernommen haben
und jetzt wäre doch eigentlich die
Gelegenheit gewesen in diesem Gesetz mal
endlich ihren Worten Taten folgen zu
lassen
Anreize zu setzen für diese
Rückverlagerung der Produktion und sie
sie machen genau das Gegenteil sie
ziehen die Schrauben an und mit den
Vorschlägen die sie dort gemacht haben
werden sie auch noch den letzten
arzneimittelproduzenten nach Asien
vertreiben meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wir haben hier in Deutschland
schon längst die Welt dümmste
Energiepolitik und das nächste Kapitel
ist jetzt noch die weltdümmste
arzneimittelpolitik
wir haben genau in diesem Zusammenhang
einige Vorschläge gemacht und wir wollen
doch in die gleiche Richtung also folgen
sie denen doch bitte sorgen wir
gemeinsam dafür dass der
arzneimittelproduktionsstandort
Deutschland gestärkt wird und sorgen wir
auch gemeinsam dafür dass die Menschen
hier in Deutschland sicher jederzeit mit
Arzneimittel versorgt werden folgen Sie
unseren Anträgen ich danke Ihnen
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Maximilian Mordhorst und er ist Mitglied
im Finanzausschuss frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es wurde
angesprochen 17 Milliarden Euro Defizit
und darüber müssen wir reden ich glaube
jeder der in der Grundschule den
Matheunterricht besucht hat sollte
wissen dass das schwierige
Entscheidungen erfordert mich wundert
vor allem dass vor diesem Hintergrund
die Unionsfraktion ihren ersten Rede
Slot dem Vertreter einer Landesregierung
in Deutschland gibt die in den letzten
Jahren die größte nehmermentalität an
den Tag gelegt hat die wir erlebt haben
die unter anderem mit dafür
verantwortlich sind dass wir jetzt in
dieser Situation sind lieber Herr
hollitschek sie haben sie haben sich
gewundert dass der Bundesfinanzminister
nicht dieses Gesetz einbringt sie sind
aber selbst hier und reden ich habe mich
schon gefragt warum machen sie das
eigentlich fünf Stunden Anreise aus
Bayern nachher geht es wieder fünf
Stunden zurück was sie machen wollen
haben sie überhaupt nicht vorgestellt
das kann doch nicht heißt nur für ein
selfie mit Jens Spahn gewesen sein
stattdessen
stattdessen lesen Sie einen Wunschzettel
vor ich habe mal ein bisschen ich habe
mal ein bisschen mitgeschrieben Beiträge
soll niedrig bleiben der Bundeszuschuss
soll hoch beim Wohngeld soll noch mehr
gemacht werden was wollen Sie denn
machen wir machen wir haben als Bund
eine schwierige finanzpolitische Lage
die Länder werden Überschüsse erzielen
da stimmt etwas in der
Verhältnismäßigkeit nicht ich würde mir
wünschen dass sie beim nächsten Mal wenn
sie hier vortragen ist ja schön wenn die
bundesratsbank nicht ganz leer ist aber
auch mal ein bisschen darüber berichten
was Bayern denn tun möchte um dieses
gemeinsame Problem zu lösen
ich will deswegen für die FDP-Fraktion
ganz klar sagen ich habe auch bei ihnen
vor allem in dieser Woche sehr genau
zugehört wir haben auf einer Seite die
Situation dass wir die Schuldenbremse
einhalten müssen weil wir sonst
finanzpolitische Probleme bekommen die
Zinskosten werden schon nächstes Jahr
auf 30 Milliarden Euro steigen und wer
nicht wie die Linke ein
Subventionsprogramm für Banken und
Investmentfonds machen will der muss
wenig Schulden machen auf der anderen
Seite haben wir extreme
Herausforderungen zu bewältigen und dann
sehe ich von der Unionsfraktion die
ganze Woche nur neue Ausgaben Vorschläge
es hat nicht mal ein Jahr gedauert dass
sie ohne jegliche
Finanzierungsvorschläge immer wieder
neue Ideen haben wo man mehr Geld
ausgeben könnte wo man weniger Geld
einnehmen könnte wir haben das bei allen
möglichen Debatten erlebt ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir in ihnen auch als
Oppositionsfraktion eine stärkere
Unterstützerin beim Bereich
finanzpolitische Solidarität bei
möglichst Schuldenbremse und
ausgeglichenen Haushalten bekommen das
wäre etwas wovon wir in Deutschland
profitieren können und nicht diese immer
größer und länger werdenden Wunschzettel
in Deutschland wir werden jetzt
unangenehme Entscheidungen treffen Karl
Lauterbach hat es vorgestellt es wurde
dann gleich nach seiner Rede wieder
abgeräumt hat um möglichst wenig Polemik
gebeten aber werden unangenehme
Entscheidungen treffen das muss man den
Menschen auch mal ehrlich sagen ich bin
der Überzeugung wir müssen diesen Weg
den wir jetzt beschritten haben
weitergehen und notwendige Maßnahmen als
ampelregierung auch dann treffen wenn
Sie kurzfristig unpopulär sind ich würde
mir wünschen dass möglichst viele aus
der Opposition diesen Mut auch haben und
dass wir gemeinsam dafür einstehen
einerseits finanzpolitische Solidarität
zu gewährleisten aber andererseits auch
die Herausforderungen zu bewältigen die
jetzt vor uns stehen ohne in Populismus
zu verfallen vielen Dank
sagt Maximilian Mordhorst aus der
FDP-Fraktion und wir sind bei der
drittletzten Rednerin in dieser Debatte
angekommen die Jana Stöcker wird das
sein aus der Unionsfraktion und sie ist
Mitglied im Gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren eines ist klar die
Finanzen der gesetzlichen Krankenkassen
werden im kommenden Jahr ein enormes
Defizit aufweisen nicht leicht aber wie
hoch der Fehlbetrag nun tatsächlich sein
wird die 17 Milliarden Euro das zeichnet
sich jetzt schon ab sind werden nicht
ausreichend und die Folgejahre sehen
nicht besser aus daher ist es umso
wichtiger strukturelle und vor allem
nachhaltige Reformschritte zu gehen und
zwar jetzt ankündigen haben wir genug
gehabt
Herr Minister was Sie bei diesem
Gesetzentwurf machen ist kreativlos mit
heißer Nadel gestrickt und rein auf
kurzfristigen Ertrag angelegt sie drehen
allein an den Stellschrauben
rücklageneinnahmen und Ausgaben aller
beteiligten Akteure der hessische
Ministerpräsident Boris rein formulierte
kürzlich zu recht schnelles Geld durch
schnelle Schnitte sämtliche Bereiche
unseres Gesundheitswesens werden bis zur
Schmerzgrenze belastet Herr Minister
wird dem vorliegenden Entwurf schaffen
sie ein destabilisierungsgesetz das
haben verschiedene Kollegen hier auch
schon so genannt und gefährden sowohl
des Gesundheitssystem als auch die
Versorgung der Versicherten und
Patienten in Deutschland von wegen die
kriegen nichts mit und keine
Leistungskürzungen und nicht nur das sie
gefährden zudem Deutschland als Standort
für Innovation und Investitionen
Flickschusterei tritt an die Stelle von
sogar in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschriebenen strukturellen
Maßnahmen warum setzen Sie den höheren
Zuschuss an die gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen für Arbeitslosengeld 2
Bezieher nicht um damit würden die
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung auf
einen Schlag und jedes Jahr mit rund 10
Milliarden Euro mindestens entlastet
werden und zwar nachhaltig und
langfristig
in jedem Wirtschaftsbetrieb gilt Kosten
Transparenz dort wo und wie die Kosten
entstehen müssen sie auch abgebildet und
gedeckt werden und für die Finanzierung
der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
gilt dies bisher nicht eines der größten
Löcher in der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung entsteht genau
dadurch dass die Gesundheitsversorgung
der Menschen die Arbeitslosengeld II
beziehen einfach nicht kostendeckend
durch den Bund finanziert wird es geht
dabei nicht um Kleingeld liebe Frau
Behrens sondern zehn Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr ein Leck das aktuell durch ihre
Regierung Herr Minister repariert werden
könnte
die Gesundheitsversorgung von Menschen
die Arbeitslosengeld II beziehen wird in
der jetzigen Struktur von den
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern die
in die Kranken gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung einzahlen
mitgetragen und diese werden nur mit
einer Beitragserhöhung zusätzlich zur
den sonstigen gestiegenen
Lebenshaltungskosten zur Kasse gebeten
und zudem werden die Beiträge die die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
den vergangenen Jahren bereits in ihre
Krankenkassen geleistet haben stark
abgeschmolzen obwohl sie eine wichtige
Rücklage für die Krankenkassen und die
Liquiditätsreserve für die den
Gesundheitsfonds sind und die Sorge
treibt unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
Recht um dass die abgebauten Reserven
der Kassen absehbar zu weiteren
Beitragssteigerung führen werden
warum will man dynamisieren sie
dahingegen dem Bundeszuschuss nicht der
Ausgleich aus Steuermitteln steht doch
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag und zwar
jetzt und nicht wieder als Ankündigung
ein einmaliger
ein einmaliger zusätzlicher
Bundeszuschuss wie sie Ihnen vorschlagen
verknüpft mit einem bundesdarlehen
stellt sicher keinen nachhaltigen
Finanzierungsbeitrag zur Sicherung der
GKV-Finanzierung da diese Ampel hat
offensichtlich nicht mal die Kraft die
eigenen Vorhaben umzusetzen wir fordern
Sie daher auf den vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf zu überarbeiten und
unser Gesundheitswesen nicht weiter zu
belasten der vorgelegte Entwurf löst
nicht die Probleme der
Krankenversicherung erschafft neue und
ist daher der falsche Weg
Diana Stöcker aus der Unionsfraktion und
ihr folgt jetzt in dieser ersten
Beratung eines Gesetzentwurfs des der
Bundesregierung mit deren mit dessen
Hilfe wenn es der Meinung Gesetz ist die
Finanzlage der Krankenkassen
stabilisiert und verbessert werden soll
Heike Behrens gesundheitspolitische
Sprecherin der SPD-Fraktion
Kollegen
die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung hat
sich in pandemiezeiten als stabiler
Faktor erwiesen und trotzdem hat diese
größte Gesundheitskrise der
Nachkriegszeit Spuren hinterlassen
überfälliger Reformen wurden hint
angestellt finanzielle Polster
aufgebraucht entschiedene Maßnahmen sind
jetzt notwendig um die gute und
solidarische Gesundheitsversorgung in
unserem Land für alle zu sichern
in Krisenzeiten
gilt es die Reihen zu schließen und
zusammen zu stehen da ist es mehr als
befremdlich wenn die Fraktion die in den
letzten zehn Jahren das
Gesundheitsministerium geführt die
Gesundheitsminister gestellt und ganz
wesentlich zu der aktuellen
kostendynamik beigetragen hat jetzt mit
dem Finger auf die ampelregierung zeigt
sie als cdu/csu waren es nur mal ein
Beispiel die trotz offensichtlicher
jahrelanger Ausgaben Zuwächse bei
patentierten Arzneimitteln die Reformen
im amnokverfahren auf die lange Bank
geschoben haben und das obwohl allen
Kennern der Reformbedarf längst klar war
das gehen wir jetzt an
der vorliegende Gesetzentwurf bietet
eine gute Grundlage um die dringend
notwendige zeitnah Stabilisierung der
kassenfinanzen zu gewährleisten aber uns
allen ist klar dass damit noch keine
nachhaltige Konsolidierung erreicht wird
um unser Gesundheitssystem auf einem
guten Qualitätsniveau funktions- und
leistungsfähig zu halten ist es
notwendig Effizienz Reserven zu heben
und die überfälligen Strukturreformen
auf den Weg zu bringen das haben wir uns
als Ampelkoalition nicht nur vorgenommen
sondern das packen wir an
im ersten Schritt mit den nun zu
diskutierenden Maßnahmen zur
kurzfristigen Kostendämpfung aber eben
im zweiten Schritt mit den langfristig
wirksamen Strukturmaßnahmen die bis Ende
Mai nächsten Jahres vorliegen werden und
selbstverständlich werden wir dafür
sorgen dass Krankenhäuser Gesundheits-
und Pflegeeinrichtungen nicht von den
aktuellen Preissteigerungen überfordert
werden auch daran arbeitet die Regierung
gerade mit Hochdruck und Minister Karl
Lauterbach hat zugesagt in Kürze dazu
einen konkreten Vorschlag vorzulegen ja
ich habe es vorhin bereits gesagt in
Krisenzeiten heißt es zusammen zu stehen
jede und jeder muss einen Beitrag dazu
leisten damit die Krise nicht zum
Kollaps wird
dass die Kritik an diesen Gesetzentwurf
nun aus allen unterschiedlichen
Richtungen kommt kann ich verstehen es
zeigt aber auch dass hier eben alle ein
Stück weit in die Verantwortung genommen
werden
und da muss ich einfach doch noch mal
auch auf das eingehen was der
Gesundheitsminister aus Bayern vorhin
hier gesagt hat denn es reicht nicht
wenn die CDU und CSU
Ministerpräsidenten oder
Gesundheitsminister hier immer nur mit
dem Finger auf dem Bund zeigen und das
Geld vom Bund einfordern Jana Stamm hat
es vorhin am Thema Krankenhäuser auf den
Punkt gebracht
jahrelang haben hier die Bundesländer
eben die Investitionsfinanzierung nicht
ausreichend gemacht und haben damit
Mittel aus dem Solidarsystem
herausgesaugt und wir haben heute die
Situation dass in vielen Bereichen eben
die Krankenhäuser tatsächlich marode
sind und dringend auf Hilfe angewiesen
sind und das ist im Wesentlichen die
Verantwortung die auf Länderseite
wahrgenommen werden muss
und ich sage Ihnen auch wir werden sie
im nächsten Jahr stellen denn wenn es
jetzt um die notwendigen
Strukturreformen geht dann werden wir
auch darüber reden müssen ob nicht die
Arzneimittel bei der Mehrwertsteuer
entlastet werden müssen es ist doch
nicht nachvollziehbar das
tierarztneimittel den mit niedrigen
Mehrwertsteuersatz belastet werden aber
die human Arzneimittel mit dem Vollen
meierwald-steuersatz und dann
diskutieren wir mal ob die Länder
bereits sind ihre Verantwortung
wahrzunehmen
und ob in diesem Gesetzentwurf ob der
ausreichend ob es darin ausreichend
gerecht zugeht oder ob das eine oder
andere vielleicht noch geändert werden
müssen das werden wir sehr sorgfältig im
Rahmen des nun beginnenden
parlamentarischen Verfahrens prüfen und
diskutieren für meine Fraktion
jedenfalls kann ich schon jetzt sagen
dass wir durchaus noch Redebedarf haben
wie wir auch das auf den Weg bringen
können was wir ganz konkret im
Koalitionsvertrag miteinander vereinbart
fahren lassen Sie uns heute und im
weiteren parlamentarischen Verfahren
intensiv und respektvoll diskutieren
vielen Dank
Heike Behrens war dass sie
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Fraktion war heute morgen um Viertel
von neun schon bei uns im Interview
gemeinsam mit seppen Müller aus der
Unionsfraktion das können sie nachgucken
über unsere Social Media Kanäle auch auf
der Homepage und über kurz oder lang
sicherlich auch auf unserem
Youtube-Kanal wir sind beim letzten
Redner dieser Debatte das ist Georg
kippels aus der Unionsfraktion
Aufmerksamkeit auf ein ganz speziellen
Punkt zu der lenken gesundheit ist ein
hohes Gut und Gesundheit ist ein teures
Gut im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes jeden
Tag investieren wir eine Milliarde Euro
in unser Gesundheitssystem die
finanziellen Herausforderungen sind
jetzt ausführlich dargestellt worden und
ich wende mich einer Bemerkung von
Minister Lauterbach zu der davon
gesprochen hat dass wir
innovationsbereit bleiben wollen und
keine Leistungskürzungen vornehmen
wollen machen wir die Probe aufs Exempel
anhand dieses Gesetzes und wenden wir
uns den seltenen Krankheiten zu die dort
mehr am Rande aber von prominenter
Bedeutung erwähnt sind was sind seltene
Krankheiten vier Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland leben mit einer solchen
Erkrankung aber sind insgesamt ca 8.000
verschiedene Krankheitsbilder derzeit
gibt es 138 Medikamente die man in
diesem Bereich nach einer 20 Jahre alten
EU-Verordnung offen drachsenend eine
spezielle
zulassungsmethode ist angewendet worden
drei schweren und tödlich verlaufenden
Erkrankungen und ohne entsprechende
vergleichstherapien werden diese
Medikamente von der EMA der europäischen
medikamentenagentur zugelassen und
können dann in die Therapie kommen was
ist tatsächlich das verbreitungsbild
mehr als fünf Menschen dürfen von 10.000
Menschen dürfen nicht an dieser
Krankheit leiden ohne dass es dann zum
Ausfall aus dieser Kategorisierung kommt
diese Medikamente sind äußerst aufwendig
und vor allen Dingen sehr teuer zu
entwickeln weil die Patientengruppen
sehr klein sind und die Möglichkeiten
für die Durchführung von Studien
infolgedessen sehr erschwert sind was
sagt das GKV
finanzierungsstabilisierungsgesetz zu
diesem Themenbereich es ist eigentlich
eine vielleicht zunächst mal belanglose
Regelung nämlich die Tatsache dass die
Umsatzschwelle in der diese Medikamente
vergütet werden und eingeordnet werden
von jährlich 50 auf 20 Millionen
reduziert werden klingt zunächst mal
nicht besonders
von besonderer Tragweite hat aber auf
die Anwendung und vor allen Dingen die
forschungsfähigkeit für diese
Medikamente eine enorme Tragweite denn
sinkt man und übersteigt man diese
Umsatzschwelle ist das Medikament nach
der normalen Regelung der
zusatznutzenbewertung des amnock
Arzneimittel neuordnungsgesetzes aus dem
Jahre 2011 einer Zulassung zu
unterziehen ein sehr komplexes Verfahren
und vor allen Dingen für diese
Medikamente deshalb so problematisch
weil häufig zu diesem Zeitpunkt die
notwendigen Studien der Studie der
Studienphase 3 mit entsprechenden Daten
nicht vorliegen und die ganz konkrete
Besorgnis besteht dass auf diese Art und
Weise die Medikamente entweder vom Markt
genommen folgen oder aber erst gar nicht
in die Anwendung kommen zusätzlich gibt
es dann noch Regelungen die sich im
Hinblick auf die Kombinationstherapien
mit einem zwangsabschlag beschäftigen
die Vorgaben für den Zusatznutzen sind
geregelt und bei verwürfen durch
unwirtschaftliche Packungsgrößen gibt es
auch Abschläge insgesamt die gesamte
Maßnahme führt dazu dass eine wirklich
gute Entwicklung in Deutschland zu
entwickeln der orphan Drax gestoppt wird
möglicherweise einen Rückfall in die
Zeit vor das anglog erfolgt und damit
haben wir eine Leistungskürzung durch
die Hintertüre und damit auch eine
Schädigung der Innovationsfähigkeit der
deutschen Pharmaindustrie
und wie wichtig gerade kleine Schritte
erste Schritte sind haben wir bei
biontech erlebt deshalb entweder ist
diese Regelung für die seltenen
Krankheiten im Gesetz schlicht und
ergreifend ein Systemfehler das wäre ein
Skandal wäre es beabsichtigt wäre es
noch ein viel größerer Skandal deshalb
Herr Minister nehmen Sie diese Regelung
für die offenprax raus und macht sie
Politik für Menschen mit seltenen
Erkrankungen vielen Dank
georg kippels hat sich da bedankt aber
der letzte Redner in dieser Debatte und
jetzt gibt es ein paar Formalia denn in
dieser Debatte gibt es ja nicht nur den
Gesetzentwurf aus dem
Gesundheitsministerium sondern es liegen
auch mehrere Anträge vor aus den Reihen
von AFD und Linksfraktion die werden
jetzt überwiegend überwiesen werden
in die
Fachausschüsse also Gesundheitsausschuss
mal ganz weit vorne und wir gucken mal
ganz kurz rein wie die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bass das
hier gestaltet und natürlich wird in dem
federführend Gesundheitsausschuss dann
natürlich auch der
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung weiter
beraten werden bevor er hier wieder
Attraktion der cdu/cs in den Bundestag
kommt und jetzt habe ich Unternehmen
gerade gehört dieses alles schon
geleistet die Überweisungen die fällig
waren haben schon statt